[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
religion heute sind wir zu gast auf dem
monte veritas oberhalb von ascona
das ist der einzige ort in der schweiz
wo tee angebaut wird und wo es ein
bisschen aussieht als wäre man in japan
denn heute geht es bei uns um den
shintoismus das ist jene religion die es
eigentlich nur in japan gibt über 80.000
shinto schreine soll es geben erkennbar
an den typischen knallroten tor dem
eingangstor ist nicht exklusiv das heißt
man kann zusätzlich auch butt ist oder
christ sein warum das erträgt gleich mit
dem japanologen david karachi zuerst
aber brauche ich einen tee danke dass
sie mich empfangen
sie halten ja hier in la casa de also
dem teehaus teezeremonien ab was genau
ist der zweck dieser termin die
teezeremonie wurde erst von
buddhistischen mönchen praktiziert sie
haben die philosophie dass zähne in die
zeremonie eingebracht sie malten cent
buddhismus oder ja den zehn buddhismus
die zeremonie besteht aus vier aspekten
harmonie respekt reinheit und stille
zwischen gast und mir die die zeremonie
durch führt aber auch der menschen
untereinander
dazu trinkt man könnte man dies also als
meditation bezeichnen
ja man kann es als meditation bezeichnen
auch für mich selbst ist es eine
meditation wenn ich die zeremonie
vorbereitet hat der gast das tor durch
schritten soll er seine sorgen ablegen
und seinen alltag hinter sich lassen und
sich nur auf den moment und den tee
konzentrieren
in absoluter stille tekom der
ursprünglich aus china wurde dann nach
japan eingeführt welche bedeutung hat te
heute ist essenziell für japan
die meisten menschen trinken ihn jeden
tag ob jung oder alt alle tun es
er wird zu den mahlzeiten getrunken oder
hinterher und wir trinken ihn auch zur
entspannung wichtig ist der tee auch als
empfangs getränk also um gästen die ihre
zu erweisen
interessant ist dass sie sagen man
würdet ihr zur entspannung trinken bei
unseres kritik gern als ersatz für
kaffee getrunken er um wach zu werden
je nach zubereitungsart kann er beide
wirkungen erzielen innerliche
entspannung und äusserliche munterkeit
wie kamen sie eigentlich dazu
teezeremonien durchzuführen mein vater
hat schon teezeremonien durchgeführt
es als ein team meister ja er ist dem
meister und ich konnte ihm als kind
dabei zusehen als ich in die schweiz kam
besuchte ich eines tages diesen
wunderschönen ort den monti wie rita und
entdeckte dabei dieses teehaus ich wurde
angefragt ob ich nicht teezeremonien
durchführen möchte das war der auslöser
ich begann mich ernsthaft mit
japanischer kultur auseinanderzusetzen
und ich realisierte dass ich vieles
nicht wusste
ok dann lassen sie uns ins haus gehen
und david krejci treffen
[Musik]
wir einigen uns die hände und den mund
und lassen den staub des alltags hinter
uns
[Musik]
rösler ist
herr kreative sind jetzt im zimmer das
gaza dede eben und hier werden auch
teezeremonien durchgeführt vm zuvor
erzählt dass teezeremonien oft auch eine
form von meditation seien ganz viel ist
extrem organisiert extrem konzentriert
man sieht es auch so ein bisschen in
diesem raum ist das typisch für japan
kann man sagen einerseits schon aber es
gibt ja dann auch genau das gegenteil
gerade auch im tourismus und gerade die
volksfeste wenn man die anschaut dann
ist es so dass es eigentlich ein
durchbrechen aller regeln darstellt
eigentlich wo eigentlich der ehren der
alltag nicht mehr geld gilt was
eigentlich vergleichbar ist mit dem was
wir vielleicht aus karneval bei uns
bezeichnen würden wo man aus dem alltag
aus pflicht eine neuerung stattfindet
weil man eben gerade die rege und
durchbricht und wo man beispielweise
vielleicht sieht irgendwo in kleinstadt
lokale chef manager von der lokalen bank
den man natürlich sonst nur im anzug und
krawatte und immer sehr formell reden
wird weil ja immer die bank betritt und
plötzlich rentenmarkt zu geben mit einem
leichten lendenschurz runkel nutzungen
zusammen durch die straßen
aber das geht dann eben weil das ist die
zeit der ausnahme also und am nächsten
tag kommt er dann wieder mit anzug ins
büro und die stadt und ist wieder jemand
ganz anderer sozusagen seinen
willkommene abwechslung um eben auch aus
diesen mustern dann auszubrechen diese
materie genau also den alltag würde man
so in japanischer ski bezeichnen
der mühsame schwere alltag wo man sich
eben an dieser formellen regeln halten
muss und das maz wie werden eigentlich
dass haare diese zeit der neuerung wo
man zusammen mit den göttern eine feier
ab hält und warum leben mit den gärtnern
sozusagen das rad der zeit am laufen
hält und wieder die energie erneuert
entsprechend und besonders auch über
überraschend weil ja in japan im alltag
man immer sehr formell ist oder auch
immer sehr zurückhaltend wenig emotionen
zeigt und auch in einem gespräch
beispielsweise nicht direkt oft nein
sagt einfach wenn etwas vorgeschlagen
wir gerade mit meinem geschäft
besprechungs in der schweiz genau
sondern man sagt ja wir überlegen uns
das aber ich weiß man das
und dann plötzlich hat man diese
ausnahme zeit wo sie ein sehr emotional
wird und eigentlich alle sich gehen
lassen
entsprechend gut jetzt haben sie schon
wenn sie hinduismus angesprochen darüber
wollen wir heute ja sprechen
im zentrum des skitourismus sind doch
diese kam easyjet pleiten auch geister
die können in einem fluss seien die
können einem berg sein
irgendwas das speziell geformt oder
speziell aussehen kann das kann eben kam
nie sein
haben sie eine lieblings gott reizt
natürlich werde die bekannten sie gott
hat es natürlich die sonnengöttin weil
sie natürlich auch die großartigste des
kaiser geschlechts entsprechend und
natürlich ein ganz japan entsprechend
vielleicht die bekannteste gottheit ist
natürlich spannend die sind natürlich
dann lokal gibt es dann immer ganz
eigene gottheiten die auch nur in diesem
dorf von dieser gemeinde sozusagen
verehrt werden und wo es dann auch
vielleicht aber wenn man dann genauer
mit den leuten redet auch
unterschiedlich vorstellung gibt wäre es
genau diese gottheit ist und wie sie
beispiel vielleicht eine repräsentation
auftritt ist das jetzt ein fuchs der oft
dann die gottheit sozusagen
repräsentiert oder für andere leute im
gleichen dorf kann es dann an den cryan
seien die verladen die gottheiten in den
alltag eintritt bei ihnen und gefällt
ihnen da eine gottheit eben am besten
also werden wir sehr gut gefällt ist der
bis zu das ist so eine mädels konnten
wir natürlich von tonnen fisch und
verehrt wurde mit so einem großen bauch
und er hat immer so eine flasche sagte
dabei und einen haken und bis in wien
mit vergleichen und neptun dann genauso
sehe ein gemütliche figuren dies dann
auch spät eingegangen in diese sieben
glücksgöttin japan gibt wobei die
anderen sechs könnte eigentlich alle vom
kontinent herkommen und eigentlich in
chinesischen er ursprung haben aber eben
das siebte sozusagen ist dann nimmt man
eines japanischen ursprungs da bist du
und wie es jetzt schon an klingt es gibt
extrem viele gatte ich habe in burma
gelesen ca 8 millionen man weiß es
vermutlich nicht so ganz genau
und im tor wird oft übersetzt als weg
der götter oder der gottheiten wenn es
so viele gottheiten gibt was bedeuteten
diesen weg zu gehen dass man also singt
oder begriff ist dann erst entstanden in
abgrenzung zum buddhismus der eingeführt
wurden nach japan und dort ist er auch
dass einige zeit für buddhismus werde
das putzen und in japan allgemein sind
wege sozusagen sachen die man erlernen
kann als auch ein handwerk kann ein weg
sein oder eine sportart kann ein weg
sein den weg des tees und noch einmal
diese genau oder auch der weg der cs ist
genau auch dass man erlernt wie man die
teezeremonie zeitraum acht und der
begriff schien durch die heutige
forschung wir sagen ist relativ spät und
so dominant geworden für diese
autochthonen religiösen vorstellungen
mann hat in einen begriff gegeben in
abgrenzung zum buddhismus und hat die
versucht zusammenzufassen und in einer
quelle ist dann eben von diesem nach
millionen körpern der rede die es gibt
sozusagen
aber natürlich so genau weiß das niemand
weil es eben auch nicht so irgendwo eine
aufzeichnung gibt was alles genau götter
sind im tourismus sondern je nach dem
auch lokal leute sozusagen bestimmen
können das ist jetzt unsere gottheit
aber wenn sie jeden sagen wenn das an
später begriff ist vielen dank dann
stellt ja trotzdem die frage was heißt
es diesen diesen weg zu gehen können sie
das doch noch etwas genauer erläutern
also dort ist wenig zu sehen der schink
tourismus es nicht so etwas wie eine
bekenntnis religion also ist nicht dass
irgendwann man entscheidet ich glaube
jetzt an sind touristische götter
sondern die idee dahinter ist wir haben
eine lokale gemeinschaft ein bauerndorf
oder einquartieren einer stadt und das
interagiert mit kräften in der natur und
dazu muss man auch sehen dass man sich
die kräfte natur in japan
einerseits sind sie natürlich sehr
positiv beispiel der frühling die sonne
möglich dann dass man wieder ernten kann
wieder aussagen kann aber andererseits
sind ja aber natürlich auch negativ oder
wir haben ja viele naturkatastrophen
vielleicht so viel niederschlag und dann
gedeiht die ernte nicht der zeit und man
versucht irgendwo zu interagieren mit
diesen kräften und sie so zu sagen so zu
drehen dass sie dann ins positive
gewendet werden
entsprechend sei nicht so dass diese
camille positiv belegt sind sondern sind
einfach kräfte mit denen man sich
engagieren muss unter der mensch greift
dann lenkend ein indem er quasi die
götter auch besänftigt genau er versucht
über rituale sie sozusagen auf seine
seite zu ziehen und die basis idee wäre
wenn ich das ritual richtig ausführen
dann kann ich die götter für mich
einsetzen dann helfen sie mir
und wenn es nicht klappt dann habe ich
höchstwahrscheinlich irgendeinem ritual
etwas falsch gemacht oder es ist zu
einer verunreinigung gekommen und
deswegen habe ich nicht das erreicht was
ich damit wollte und wir machen jetzt
dieses ritual richtig wie was mich
wundert wenn es ebenso viele götter gibt
kann alles mögliche man ja auch sagen
besänftigen die götter besänftigen kann
alles mögliche eine gottheit sein oder
eben diese göttliche kraft haben ja im
prinzip ist auch dort es ist nicht oder
der betrachter von außen schreibt
sozusagen diesen comic charakter einem
gegenstand einem dem auch gelacht hat
also der sagt hier haben wir eine
qualität diese tasse hat jetzt eine
besondere qualität dass sie vielleicht
aus so eine gewisse endlichkeit besitzt
aus meiner sicht und ich sie sozusagen
wie auch mit für ihr herz sprechen und
ich auch mit entsprechend ehrfurcht
tiere begegnen und so muss natürlich
sagen gerade diese gottheiten das sind
ja auch nicht jetzt in seinem
christlichen sinne allmächtige götter
sondern sind eben einfach kräfte in der
natur besondere qualitäten die wir
sozusagen vorhanden sind die ich als
mensch eben besonders positiv belegen
möchte also es geht dann eben auch um
dieses harmonische wechselspiel zwischen
quasi der menschlichen welt und dann
eben dieser göttlichen und natürlichen
welt genau und viele diesem auto die wir
vorher gesprochen aber da dieser ja das
sind ja ich jahres anlässe die befinden
und bestimmten daten statt zum beispiel
im frühling die erste aussaat wo man
eben versucht die kraft der goethe ein
zusammen dann mit dann die saat aufgeht
entsprechend und dann vielleicht ein
sehr schönes beispiel für ein solches
maß finden wir auch schon den ältesten
schriften
doch jetzt eine geschichte ein tabu
gebrochen und konnte ihn sozusagen zu
einer verunreinigung die sonnengöttin
zieht sich zurück in einer felsenhöhle
und verschließt die die welt wird dunkel
und die götter tja da müssen sie
irgendwie herauslocken
und sie bringen dann ganz viele opfer
und beten aber was dann schluss ein
erfolgreich ist und sie herauszulocken
ist das eine gute auf ein eimer steigt
einen tanz aufführt an ganz wilden und
dann auch ihre brüste und genitalien
entblößt die anderen götter brechen in
schallendes gelächter aus und dann
öffnet die sonnengöttin ein bisschen und
felsen kommt ein bisschen lauf scheinbar
nie so lachen sie genau und dann wird
sie raus gezogen und dann kommt die
sonne wieder sozusagen ihren auftakt man
kann nicht sagen oder hier sieht man
diesen zyklus der herbst der winter die
sonne zieht sich zurück und über einen
macho über eine gemeinsame feier holen
wir sie dann wieder zurück und halten so
sagen eben dieses rad derzeit am laufen
und sorgen dafür dass wieder der
frühling und der sommer kommt da sieht
man auch dass die täter offenbar auch
menschliche züge haben wenn sie aus
neugierig ticket in quasi raus kommt und
was mich da noch besonders interessiert
hat in der beschäftigung jetzt mit dem
städtischen tourismus vor diesem
gespräch ist zu sehen dass es einen ganz
praktischen bezug hat wenn man das jetzt
auch vergleicht mit dem christentum
wurst zum beispiel auch um jenseits und
so weiter geht geht es im shintoismus
ganz stark darum ich gehe in einen
schreien um eine gute prüfung zu machen
um eine gute operation zu bekommen ja
also sieht man sehr problematischen
sozusagen haltung gegenüber vielleicht
generell gegenüber religion aber ganz
besonders in tourismus auch weil es eben
in japan gleichzeitig auch den
buddhismus gibt der sozusagen ebenso
zusammen die frauen des jenseits der
erlösung derzeit abdeckt und damit der
shintoismus sich wirklich auf das leben
konzentriert gibt auch so diese einfache
einteilung die natürlich und data nicht
stehen dass man sagt dass im tourismus
ist für das leben da und der buddhismus
ist für den tod da entsprechend und eben
gerade im touristischen oft eingesetzt
werden was ich geburt eines kindes
autofahrt prüfung was auch immer ich geh
mal in den schreien ich bringe ein
kleines sozusagen gabe hängen vielleicht
so ein schildchen auf wo ich meinen
wunsch gegenüber den göttern äußere und
wenn es nichts nützt dann schadet es
zumindest natürlich auch nicht da ich so
ein bisschen die einstellung von air
partner der wichtigen punkt an dem es ja
auch noch dass es eben offenbar ganz
normal ist schindler ist und buddhist
gleichzeitig zu sein was dann wiederum
für leute aus dem westen oft besonders
an
und weil der bekenntnis religionen
kennen es gibt einen glauben den mann
verfolgt und nicht ich glaube an an
buddha und mohammed und jesus
gleichzeitig ja also das ist natürlich
wichtig eben indem man sozusagen in eine
gemeinde hineingeboren wird ist man teil
dieser schink touristische gemeinde und
man führte im gewisse rituale durch das
gehört sozusagen zum alltag leben dazu
geben zu diesen feierlichkeiten die man
durch führt und gleichzeitig ist aber
auch so dass eigentlich jede familie in
japan seit dem siebzehnten jahrhundert
in einem buddhistischen tempel
eingeschrieben ist um zu beweisen dass
die buddhisten sind und nicht christen
und das führt natürlich dazu dass auch
unabhängig davon ob ich jetzt an genau
diese buddhistische lehre glaube über
die familie ich wiederum zu an
buddhistischen tempel gehöre und wenn
jemand stirbt das der familie dann wird
man ein fertigungs ritual dieses
buddhistischen tempels dieser
buddhistischen schule durchführen also
auch dort selbst auch beim buddhismus
ist eigentlich zu anklagen erkenntnis
und persönliche überzeugung wichtig so
dass ein und könnte dann eine familien
religion oder auch eine
familientradition wie man mit dem tod
umgeht
über ihm gewisse rituale das ist glaube
ich noch kurz erklären weshalb man nicht
christ sein sollte beziehungsweise sich
als buddhist ausweisen
also das gewissen luca im 16 jahrhundert
nach japan und die haben natürlich auch
begonnen zu missionieren und relativ
erfolgreich auch und dann im frühen 17
jahrhundert kam es wieder zu großen
reichseinigung dass es entstanden wieder
sozusagen fest der politische strukturen
mit dem tokugawa barcoo fuhren der
spitze eine neue regierung und dann im
frühen 17
jahrhundert gab es aber einen aufstand
der christen gegen diese neue regierung
der wurde niedergeschlagen und in der
folge davon hat aber das baku wo
beschlossen das land abzuschließen
man hat nur noch mit den holländern
handel getrieben weil die sozusagen
einverstanden waren dass sie auch handel
treiben ohne gleichzeitig christlich
missionieren zu können die spanier und
die portugiesen wollten das nicht und
die hat man dann sozusagen
ausgeschlossen vom handel und
gleichzeitig hat man eben dann
festgelegt jede familie muss sich in
einem tempel ein schreiben um zu
beweisen dass sie keine christen sind
weil man sozusagen die christen aus eine
externe kraft oder ein externer religion
eingeschätzt hat die sozusagen das
politische system destabilisieren
könnten
was mich noch interessiert wenn sie
jetzt sagen dass diese göttliche kraft
eben ganz oft auch in eben naturphänomen
also steinen tieren überhaupt bäumen zum
beispiel vorkommt hat es auch einen
rückschluss oder kann man einen
rückschluss ziehen auf eine form von
klimaschutz und so weiter oder kann man
es nicht beobachten sowohl auch gesagt
da einerseits ist natürlich auch das
argument von umweltaktivisten derzeit in
japan dass man ja eben den shinto hat
dass das eher eine form von natur
verehrung und interaktion oder
harmonische beziehung mit der natur nahe
legt das ist ein argument das ein
argument das muss natürlich sagen auch
in der modernisierung in japan hat in
der industrialisierung oder man kann
auch sagen im schenkte man versucht er
die natur für sich selbst zu nutzen oder
eine instrumentalisierung der natur so
wie wir sie auch im westen kennen und
auch da sagt man natürlich sehr auf die
spitze getrieben gerade in der 15 und 60
jahren beim hoch wachstum hat man
natürlich eigentlich ohne rücksicht auf
die natur die ganzen das team aufgebaut
was er dann zu ganz großen
umweltverschmutzung problemen in japan
geführt hat also da muss man einfach
sehen
es kann als argument verwendet werden
aber man kann den schinken auch
sozusagen drehen als eine genau um die
natur sozusagen auszunutzen und was ist
denn dran an den gedanken dass eben
aufgrund dessen dass jedes objekt auch
diesen diese diese göttlichkeit haben
kann das schien touristen oder eben
japaner einen einfacheren zugang oder
vielleicht sich weniger probleme machen
mit dem umgang mit robotern gut doch
gana durchsagen einerseits ist sich ein
faktor wie gesagt hat diese taste könnte
jetzt für mich auch eine art kam ich
sein oder auch ein schöner stein oder
besonders glänzende käfig oder käfer das
alles könnte für mich sozusagen diese
spezielle eigenschaft haben und als
camille gelten
und da ist natürlich auch dass man
sozusagen wie sieht ja der roboter ist
auch beseelt und entsprechend auch eine
positive sodann konnotation
hineininterpretieren kann nicht als eine
gefahr sondern eben auch etwas was ich
ins positive wenden kann was ich auch
wieder für mich selber ausnutzen kann
natürlich sagen hören ist das nicht der
einzige faktor sondern wir haben auch in
japan wo ja gerade im alltag der leute
die sagten wir modernisierung
natürlich spät beginnt erst in späten
50er jahren uns natürlich eine erfahrung
gerade dort machen dass ihr alltag sehr
viel einfacher und angenehmer geworden
ist durch technologischen fortschritt
und das natürlich vielleicht auch
stärker vor allem auch seit den 70er
jahren sich in japan gehalten hat weil
was wir vorher angesprochen auch die
probleme mit der umweltverschmutzung
konnte man eigentlich mehrheitlich mit
technologischen lösungen in den griff
bekommen und das hat natürlich auch den
glauben an die technologie sozusagen
also ein lösungs element für die zukunft
weiter gestärkt in japan ja wenn wir
jetzt definieren wollen weil wir kreisen
ja so ein bisschen um diesen begriff
coaching tourismus herum wenn wir jetzt
definieren wollen was china eigentlich
ist dann scheint es mir doch ziemlich
schwierig zu sein aufgrund dessen dass
es ja keinen stifter gibt es gibt keine
form von offenbarung nur sehr wenige
schriften die auf die man sich rück
bezieht das macht das ganze schon
ziemlich schwierig nicht
ich glaube wichtig zu sehen wie beim für
das wäre einerseits eben was ich vorher
ein bisschen beschrieben haben mit
diesen markt zu diese lokale oder diese
naturreligion haben oder diese
volkszählung könnte man sagen also die
interaktion einer lokalen gemeinschaft
mit der natur und gleichzeitig haben wir
auch in der japanischen geschichte auch
darauf dass das schämte sich entwickelt
hat so etwas zur legitimierung von
politischen strukturen die entstanden
sind also eigentlich eine hoch religion
klar dort hat man lange nicht so
schriften gehabt die kommen relativ spät
beim tourismus und eindeutig in der
reaktion zum buddhismus und auch der
inhalte sehr stark buddhistisch geprägt
was dann eben auch dazu führt dass man
sagt was wir heute dass china bezeichnet
sind nicht die ursprünglich autochthonen
religions- vorstellungen und praktiken
diebe in japan hatten vor der einführung
des buddhismus sondern ist etwas was ich
abgemischt hat mit dem buddhismus aber
klar wichtig ist es gibt in diesem sinne
nicht eine klare definition wo es muss
anfängt und endet was er inhaltlich
sondern auch zeitlich gesehen ja also es
eigentlich so wie offen und es ist ja
auch eben teil einerseits des alltages
aber andererseits auch dieser erneuerung
der energie sozusagen des tages
entsprechend also im zentrum steht dann
eben nicht eine religiöse doktrin
sondern rituale
praxis deshalb gibt es auch so viele
schweine dann die man besucht
und da muss man sich den oder die
überwiegende mehrheit dieser scheine
sind wieder verankert in einer rally
lokalen gemeinschaft und die werden dann
von den lokalen bauern führen diese
masse die beispielsweise durch klar es
gibt dann auch gewisse schreine die eben
auch ein politischer bedeutung haben
bekannte sie sicher der isar in der
sonnengöttin der natürlich dem
kaisergeschlecht zugeordnet ist und
daher natürlich eine politische funktion
und dort findet man entsprechend auch
elaboriert rituale und auch rituale die
natürlich nicht diese karneval haften
feste umfassend und das ist natürlich
ein sehr formeller anlass war viel
stärker an der teezeremonie sozusagen
auch im äußeren erscheinungsbild und ist
das dann auch der grund das ist ebenso
stark diese territorium gebunden ist
dass der shintoismus eigentlich fast nur
in japan gelebt wird und quasi nicht die
attraktivität genießt wie beispielsweise
eben hierzulande der buddhismus sich
einerseits man muss auch sagen der
skitourismus missioniert eigentlich
nicht er ist ja lokal verankert und es
gibt auch keinen grund es zu versuchen
schon ins nachbardorf zu tragen die
haben ihre eigenen göttern also
entsprechend müssen wir nicht versuchen
sie zu überzeugen von unserem geld dann
entsprechend und dann politischer ebene
ist natürlich immer in japan angeboten
oder es ist anders kaisergeschlecht
geboren und damit auch das japanische
territorium die einzige zeit wo
sozusagen schießt tourismus versucht
wurde außerhalb des kerngebietes zu
verbreiten war während der kolonialzeit
dann hat man begonnen in korea und
taiwan in touristischer schweine zu
errichten
auch mit der idee wirklich aus der
bevölkerung dort auch sozusagen subjekte
des kaisers zu machen und auch
touristisch einzubinden
natürlich am ende des tollen die auszeit
wieder ganz verschwunden ist in korea
und taiwan
aber dann verstehe ich das richtig dass
auch diese offenheit ist sehr einfach
gemacht hat für die tradition an dem
sechsten jahrhundert dann wie sie es
gesagt haben der buddhismus nach japan
kam dass man die elemente da auch in
kultur irrt hat gewissermaßen
ein konglomerat von verschiedenen
religiösen ritualen oder überzeugungen
gebaut hat jaja buddhismus ist auch
offen jeweils für um lokale religion
sowie zu in kooperieren in sein gebäude
also bekannterweise auch ein jahrhundert
wo eben die sonnengöttin auch ein
moralisch dort wo sie zu erkennen gibt
dass auch sie eine repräsentation dieser
kosmologischen buddhistische kraft ist
dass er sich eine art polizei weist in
einer druck- und da sieht man so beginnt
diese stärke abmischung von buddhismus
und hinduismus in japan die dann sich
sehr lange sehr komplex weitere
entwickelt eigentlich bis zum späteren
19 jahrhundert wurden zuge des nation
building sda ich versucht wurde das
wieder stärker zu trennen
ich muss sagen das ist eigentlich
unheimlich verwirrend weil wie weiß man
denn genau was jetzt was jetzt wirklich
so ist wenn im grunde genommen dieser
verschiedenen elemente zusammen kommen
und es auf eine gewisse weise offenbar
auch nicht so was gibt wie häretiker
oder sowas oder wie wir setzen manchmal
aus dem christentum kennen also waren es
gibt nicht die zentrale schule die
festlegt was jetzt eigentlich der
schenkte umfasst etc
man muss das sagen auch für die
japanische bevölkerung studien zeigen
wenn die einen buddhistischen tempel
oder einen gang durch den schreiben
besuchen
dass sich eine mehrheit der wirkung
nicht ganz klar ist ist das jetzt ein
buddhistisches gebäude oder das ist
jetzt ein touristischer bezirk das heißt
es ist auch nicht wichtig für sie diesen
formaten ja weil sie oft ja auch zu
befristen tempo und hingehen um so an
einen nutzen in jenen diesseits zu
bekommen oder also nicht so sehr hin
geht um für die erlösung im jenseits zu
beten beispiel sondern auch da was auch
immer aufnahmeprüfungen zeit dabei stand
da geld abzuholen
also da haben wir auch eine sehr starke
überlappung der beiden oder wir haben ja
auch wenn wir buddhistische tempel
bezirke anschauen dann haben wir immer
einen statistischen schrein in der regel
in diesen tempelbezirk der dann die
lokale schutz gottheit von diesem tempo
ist und darüber wacht als beispiel also
nicht niederbrennt spricht also auch da
sehen wir diese sehr starke abmischung
der beiden dass er die unterstützen sich
quasi gegenseitig genau weiß es
natürlich wenn man sagen ist durch
verschiebungen die dollars war so könnte
man bereits an der buddhismus war gerade
dominante universal religion um mit der
zeit beginnt dann sich der skitourismus
auch wieder ein stück weit stärker
abzugrenzen da gerade aus hoch religion
versuchen wir noch historisch etwas
ordnung reinzubringen
es gibt meines wissens zwei theorien
brasilia alt dass der shintoismus ist
sie haben es zur forschung angedeutet
die eine ist eben zu sagen
jean todt ist die uhr religion ja man
soll da gibt es die andere die sagt nein
nein das ist eigentlich eine erfindung
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts und zuvor
hat es so was wie eine eine eigene
shinto religion nicht gegeben liegt die
wahrheit irgendwo dazwischen höhere muss
man sie suchen ja irgendwo sagen was man
eigentlich so im neunzehnten jahrhundert
angenommen hat ist dass man versuchen
kann den skitourismus von aus einem
buddhistischen elementen zu reinigen und
dann auf diese japanische uhr religion
kommt wird und man hat das auch ein
stück weit versucht zu machen im zuge
eben der nationenbildung um auch diese
eigene identität heraus zu gründen und
eine basis für die neuen nation aus
stadt zu etablieren
aber als der heutigen forschung würden
wir sagen das ist nicht möglich weil
selbst die frühesten schriften die wir
haben in japan haben eindeutig
buddhistischen einfluss sollte man kann
das ganz leicht nachweisen sind wie alt
dieser ältesten lassen achten
jahrhundert und auch dort sehen wir eben
eindeutig buddhistische ideen aber auch
touristische ideen die buddhismus in
seiner entwicklung über china mit
aufgenommen hat die dann dort hinein
wirken sozusagen und in dem sinne ist er
vielleicht schon richtig sagen der
shinto auch dieser begriff wird eben
sehr wichtig im streit neunzehnten
jahrhundert und auch in abgrenzung zum
buddhismus und für die identitätsbildung
des neuen nationalstaates eine zentrales
element das ist hochinteressant
das führt mich zur nächsten frage
nämlich es gibt ja so einen entstehungs
mythos der besagt dass japan ein götter
land sei bzw von göttern eigentlich
geschaffen und da dann auch die aussage
shinto ist mehr eine form von eben
ideologie das klingt bei ihnen auch so
ein bisschen als eben eine religion
was würden sie sagen stimmt das so ja
also gut und natürlich die frage wieder
wie definieren wir religion
entsprechend dazu muss man auch sagen im
japanischen mit religion eben sehr auch
von der begriff der verwendet willige
und shu qi hat man auch wieder die lehre
mit drin und deswegen auch dass viele
leute die japan denken shinto ist nicht
eine religion im engeren sinne zumindest
weil es ja nicht diese klar definierte
lehre gibt sondern sind gewisse
praktiken eine interaktion mit der natur
also man versteht unter dem begriff den
sie jetzt genannt haben
religion er dann so was wie ein
christentum ein islam also islam
christentum oder im buddhismus wo wir
die sudan haben mit wo eindeutig
verschiedene schulen unterschiedliche
lehrern betreten und beim shinto haben
wir das eben in der regel nicht und
deswegen auch dass viele leute denken
das ist nicht eine religion kommt noch
dazu dass wir im späten 19 jahrhundert
jahren eine auflage von den westlichen
kolonialmächten war damit japan die
ungleichen verträge aufheben kann mit
den westlichen mächten das ist
religionsfreiheit garantiert
gleichzeitig haben wir neue elite die
eigentlich den shintoismus versucht ins
zentrum auch identitätsbildung mit dem
tenor mit dem kaiser ins zentrum dieses
neuen nationalstaates zu bilden um das
zu lösen hat man gesagt der schinken ist
nicht eine religion sondern ist eine
tradition anknüpft wo man leicht dass
wir es den religionen rausgenommen haben
gesagt hat wir haben religionsfreiheit
aber gleichzeitig können wir keinen
staat bilden der sozusagen auf dem
kaiser im zentrum hat und damit auch
eindeutig einen schink touristischen
charakter hat und weshalb braucht man
dafür sind und weshalb hat man auf
shinto zurückgegriffen
deshalb hat man hinter letztlich als
diese uhr religion kommt zu konzipieren
begonnen der gewinn war viel wichtiger
der tenno sozusagen was wir als
japanische kaiser übersetzen wobei
sicherlich besser wäre von einem
japanischen papst zu sprechen weil ja
nicht die historisch eigentlich nur
kurze zeit wirklich die politische macht
in hat aber war immer der religiöse
oberste shinto priester der den echten
sozusagen politischen anführer
legitimiert hat oft auch eingesetzt hat
und sein
und da war natürlich so was im späten 19
jahrhundert man das bisherige regierung
eigentlich einen kommentar oder einen
aufstand dagegen stattfand die neue
elite sich irgendwo legitimieren musste
und was bietet sich da mehr an als
eigentlich den tenor sozusagen auf seine
seite zu ziehen und damit beruft man
sich auf die ganze japanische geschichte
und legitimiert damit auch diesen neuen
nationalstaaten beginnt aufzubauen weil
sie eigentlich noch geschieht ist man
stampft eigentlich innert weniger jahre
könnte man sagen von oben her in einer
form von revolution aus einem vor
modernen gesellschaft einem modernen
nation aus stadt heraus also der der
kaiser standbein im zentrum für die
bildung des nationalstaat dass das habe
ich jetzt richtig verstanden genau also
war die auch dass der kaiser und die
spitze dieses nationalstaates gestellt
es wurde dann später auch eine
verfassung gegeben eine also alles was
einen modernen staat zu sagen ausmacht
aber sind besonders in japan ist zum
beispiel wer ist der souverän
es ist nicht das volk obwohl es das
parlament wählen darf sondern ist der
kaiser der kaiser schenkt dem volk die
verfassung das war die offizielle
leseart und deswegen darf das volk das
parlament sozusagen war erteilen
entsprechend und der souverän und im
zentrum des staates bleibt aber der
kaiser
da gibt es diesen begriff verwendet hat
man gesagt guck was so viel heißt wie
starts körper und da steht eben im
zentrum dieses starts körpers ist die
ahnen linie des kaisers und das hat man
dann auch ideologisch sich darauf
abgestützt wie japan sind etwas
besonderes weil wir haben diese
ununterbrochene ahnen linie des kaisers
die hat die älteste die älteste
monarchie quasi und dann geht es eben
zurück auf diese göttliche
mythologischen tendence natürlich nicht
gegeben hatte auf 660 unserer
zeitrechnung und hat man sich darauf
zurückgeführt
man muss an ursprünglich hatte es auch
eingesetzt in abgrenzung zu china wo es
ja mehrere dynastien gibt wo man gesagt
hat dass besonderen japan ist gegenüber
china
wir haben nur eine dynastie
ununterbrochene die blutlinie zeit genau
das war also wo man sagt ja das macht
eben japan besonders und auch das macht
japan zum susanne göcke land wir sind
das auserwählte landen
sinne weil wir eben immer diesen tenno
hatten die könnte so seine repräsentiert
die ordnung oder präsentiert auf dieser
welt das ist ja hoch interessant wenn
ich das richtig verstanden habe ist es
ja tatsächlich so dass während des
zweiten weltkriegs der kaiser ja gar als
quasi göttlicher inszeniert wurde und
dann die besatzer macht die usa ihn also
quasi per befehl da degradiert hat und
gesagt er müsse öffentlich bekennen dass
er auch nur menschlich sei meine
überlegung war dann natürlich ist das
überhaupt realistisch ist ja auch eine
glaubensfrage und leuten mit
glaubensfragen irgendwelche verordnungen
zu machen das funktioniert ganz oft
nicht was natürlich stattgefunden hat
mir mehr japan sich ab 30 jahren in
expansions- kriege verstrickt hat je
mehr das militär die macht übernommen
hat je mehr ultranationalist das an
bedeutung gewonnen hat
bester stärker hat man gerade auf diesen
sind touristischen religiöse konnotation
sozusagen des staates hervorgehoben
man hatte eine mission sozusagen dann
aus der monteur als abgeleitet hat und
desto wichtiger wurde der techno
sozusagen als diese nebulöse alles
zusammenhalten die kraft im hintergrund
man sieht das auch in der frühen moderne
hat aktuell noch immer auftritt in der
öffentlichkeit der besuch bei speise die
erste stahlfabrik wenn sie auf geht s ab
dem 30 jahren verschwindet der fast aus
dem öffentlichen leben und wir sind
sonst 19.45 gast und die kapitulation
erfolgt da ist ja diese aufzeichnung von
ihm die dann im radio verkündet wird
großteil der wirkung versteht nicht was
er sagt weil er auch eine ganz besondere
sprache redet man sowas versprach den
jahren sehr sozusagen hof japanisch mit
bestimmten grammatikalische formen und
auch begriffen die man nicht im auto
außerhalb des hofes verwendet und
deshalb macht er das so
das war die rechtssprache die r sprache
oder der hof hat sich sozusagen wie
abgegrenzt von der alten wein
das um das zusammenfassen ich verstehe
es richtig r wendet sich ans volk mit
einer sprache die das tier ein großteil
des volkes nicht versteht genau wobei
man sich im klaren waren dass die
bevölkerung das nicht verstehen würde
weil es war ja noch die sprache die eine
maut tag am hof sprach sozusagen
aber die ganze japans bewirken muss
natürlich es kann nur die kapitulation
sein weil jetzt redet der tenno im radio
was er vor auch nie gemacht hat und
damit war nicht klar
und dann natürlich für die amerikaner
klar wir müssen ja eigentlich oder aus
ihrer sicht diese demokratisierung hat
nur oberflächlich geklappt das ist
eigentlich so eine quasireligiöse könnte
auch sagen kunst verblieben diese ganze
konstruktion in japan und wir müssen
eben dafür sorgen dass der tenno
sozusagen nicht mehr als vorteil gilt
sondern nur noch als symbol für den
start gehen ich das einfach zum
staatsoberhaupt wird und deswegen haben
sie dann gezwungen durchs land zu reisen
die leute zu treffen und ihnen auch zu
verkünden dass er nur sozusagen ein
normaler mensch aus fleisch und blut sei
wobei natürlich klar ist man kann sagen
bei dem das beispiel aus papst ist
bringt das ja nahe
für viele japanerinnen die natürlich
auch im bildungssystem groß geworden
sind wohin würde vermittelt wurde auch
dass sie eben da eine gottheit vor sich
haben die die geschichte japans
repräsentierte zeit war es natürlich ein
stück weit nicht nachvollziehbar dass
jetzt plötzlich ein normaler mensch sein
sollte also für diese sicher mehr
geblieben als ein normaler mensch sowie
auch für den überzeugten katholiken der
papst mehr ist als ein normaler mann so
wie ist es heute
also muss man sagen dass er stattfindet
ist gerade auch weil das so zentral war
für den nationalstaat dass die
amerikaner ganz strikt getrennt habe
staat und religion in der nachkriegszeit
und das ist natürlich eben vielen durchs
wasser aus dem rechten lager in japan
oder konservativen ein dorn im auge sie
hätten gerne wieder eine neue verfassung
in der in irgendeiner form auch wieder
das schild durch hineingeschrieben wird
also wieder stärker angeknüpft wird eben
an das system bis 1945
und sie möchten sich auch für sie ist
natürlich der trainer eben auch immer
mehr geblieben als ein normaler mensch
hat war eben immer ich sag jetzt mal ihr
papst so sagt man entsprechend möchten
sie natürlich auch dass er wieder
stärker auch in diese richtung sozusagen
eine funktion bekommt entsprechend wobei
was sicher ist was keine mehrheit in der
bevölkerung sicher finden wird ist so
eine rückkehr mit einem ei ich war
vorher ein absolutistischer herrscher
zumindest ein blatt papier
man nimmt an dass er nicht wirklich
diese funktion wahrgenommen hat aber
hätte eigentlich weg von oben diktieren
können und das wird sicher nicht
sozusagen von einer großen mehrheit der
bevölkerung unterstützen weil sie jetzt
mehrfach diese verbindung zum papst auch
gemacht haben man muss ja dazu
vielleicht sagen eben der der kaiser ist
quasi auch der oberste shinto priester
jetzt aber im vergleich eben auch zum
zum römischen katholizismus ist es ja so
dass der papst durchaus extrem viel
macht hat was die ganze lehrer was die
ganzen dogmen beinhaltet diese ganze
macht wie sie jetzt eigentlich andeuten
die comteam ja nicht zu oder insofern
ist dann die vergleich mit dem papst
hinkt ein bisschen ja sagen können dass
eben der unterschied ist es wurde ich
nie vom hof dann eine so was wie eine
touristische lehre entwickelt ja die
lehren die wir haben sind im gegenteil
es waren einzelne wichtige schreine aber
oft sind diese lehren erst entstanden
wenn sie eben nicht mal die
unterstützung hatten vom hof wo man
sozusagen sich irgendwo legitimieren
musste auch anbieter weiterhin einnahmen
zu generieren und auch neue
einnahmequellen zu suchen sollten sich
so erschließen entsprechend aber war es
eben noch nie gemacht hat oder was nie
entwickelt ist das eigentlich vom hofe
also eine zentral gesteuerte lehre
entwickelt wurde und das wird auch wie
zu sehen dass eben sehr lange der
buddhismus auch eine ganz zentrale rolle
in den ganzen staatsstrukturen gespielt
hat und eine tragende rolle gespielt hat
also mann da sieht man wieder diese
abmischung wie sowas auch nicht nötig
war so etwas wie eine touristische
zentrale geregelte leben das wollte ich
jetzt gerade fragen deshalb hat sich das
denn ich entwickelt wenn man ja genau
auf der basis des skitourismus der mann
dann als uhr religion und irgendwie auch
als wenn ich mal national ideologie dann
irgendwann inszeniert hat weshalb es
dann nicht noch mehr wie ein lehrgebäude
gegeben habe wird also man kann man so
sagen wo sich so etwas ein stück weit
zumindest entwickelt hat ist den gerade
im späten 19
mitten der zellen bilden oder dann
beginnt der staat auch zum ersten mal
regulierend einzugreifen als ag zum
beispiel schickt dann leute
und da in die dörfer und die entscheiden
das ist ein echter schreiben wir auf
hier sozusagen nationales register und
das hingegen das ist kein schein und da
wird zurzeit mit dem häretiker dann
schon ein bisschen drin ja und man kann
sie vorstand für die lokale bevölkerung
an das oft schock ein großer schock weil
sie hatten natürlich da ein vielleicht
nicht so schönen schein aber den sie
natürlich über jahrhunderte verehrt
hatten das waren ihre götter und
plötzlich kommt jetzt die der neue staat
und verkündet das gilt jetzt nicht mehr
und transportiert auch ihre götter ab
zum teil dann aus den dörfern zeitraum
was natürlich danach protest ausgelöst
habt beiden leuten um zum schluss setzt
den skitourismus doch noch in unsere
breitengrade zu bringen wollte sie
fragen es gibt ja diese aufräumen
expertin
marie konto sie hat sehr viel verdient
mit dem dass sie eben leute beibringt
wie sie ihre häuser aufräumt hat netflix
auch eine dokumentation gemacht und sie
hat ja selber auch in einem
shinto-schrein gearbeitet sieht man das
an ihrer arbeit irgendwie dass sie da
wirklich diese hintergründe hat
teilweise kann man sagen schon aber auch
da es vielleicht nicht so sehr eine
lehre die so im vordergrund steht
dahinter sondern ist es auch wieder eine
möglichkeit des zugangs sozusagen und es
klar sie kommt ja vermuten noch zu
leuten nach hause die offensichtlich
mühe haben ordnung zu halten oder auch
dinge wegzuwerfen und ich denke ja
vorgang natürlich auch damit zu tun weil
sie ja dann hinein kommt sozusagen von
außen auch mit einer ehe frucht ja
zuerst mal den haus begegnet den
einwohnern begegnet und auch der
sozusagen aus dieser ehe furcht heraus
dann mit diesen aufräumen beginnt und
dann ist es ja nicht dass man etwas weg
wird sondern habe ich mir eine
verabschiedung von einem gegenstand
stattfindet und das vielleicht auch was
dann den leuten wiederum es einfacher
macht oder dann diese person die von
außen sozusagen das wie ein anschub gibt
dann auch die möglichkeit weg gibt sich
eben von gewissen dingen zu trennen die
sich leicht aus eigenem antrieb aus
eigener kraft nicht fertig gebracht
hätten
aber hat sie den erfolg auch oder hätte
sie denn auch im in japan oder ist es
einfach prima etwas das für uns in
dieser form der exotik interessant ist
das alles natürlich sicher die exotik
man muss sagen sie ja durchaus auch
einen gewissen erfolg in japan
aber dort ist natürlich nicht so
exotisch wie vielleicht bei uns
entsprechend sie auch bezeichnet sie hat
damit begonnen als in den usa schon
gelebt entsprechend und sie hat
natürlich daneben auch weil sie
sozusagen als außenseiter in die
haushalte hineinkommt und einen fremden
zugang sozusagen auch zum aufräumen
vermitteln kann über ihre schenk
touristischen praktiken die sie mit
hinein bringt da natürlich auch so zu
sagen man kann sagen wie einen
exotischen vorteil
ich möchte dann bedanke ich mich ganz
herzlich für dieses gespräch und die
vielen aufschlussreichen gedanken hertie
ist okay hier geht es gleich weiter mit
japan und der frage nach unserer zukunft
in richter der kernspaltung und damit
verabschiede ich mich auch in die
sommerpause
in den kommenden wochen zeigen wir ihnen
eine blütenlese der vergangenen
sendungen
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen sommer
und ich freue mich sie im august wieder
zu sehen
[Musik]